hi this is a science hangout from
science mission so we have today dr.
rich and mallar with us she's from
University of Binghamton mallar dr.
Mahler as a broad training in chemical
and biomedical engineering and
specialized training in development
characterization and validation of invit
organ and tissue models her current
research includes the development of
models of a GI tract vascular
endothelium and well will our
endothelium for mechanochemical toxicity
testing mallar that melis lab builds
dynamic 3d models and our current
research as application towers
cardiovascular disease cancer and
focuses on how disruption in a tissue
local mechanical and chemical
environment can lead to the changes in
cell phenotype and initiation and
progression of diseases welcome dr.
Mahler thank you can you please it's
nice to have you thanks for taking time
to China's on hang out of course thank
you for the nice introduction and can
you please talk us about your background
education etc sure of course so I did my
bachelor's of science my BS degree at
UMass Amherst that was in chemical
engineering and when I was a sophomore
chemical engineer I started doing
research that was more in the
bioengineering area and that's where I
really started you know discovered a
love for research and really started on
my current career path so then I went to
Cornell University in ithaca new york
and i worked with dr. michael Schuler
and there I started developing organ on
a chip technology body on a chip
technology and I work to develop a
gastrointestinal tract that could be
used for drug testing
and then I did my postdoc in biomedical
engineering at Cornell University with
dr. Jonathan butcher and they are
started working in three dimensions
started working on 3d organ and tissue
models now I'm an assistant professor at
Binghamton University in the biomedical
engineering department and I've
continued that work on developing these
microfluidic tissue models okay so you
know a shot careers like deal happen to
meet any men tesoro two models oh of
course um I mean the the scientists that
I've worked under so it started again
when I was an undergraduate at UMass
Amherst i worked with susan roberts and
she was a brand new professor at the
time but she was just so enthusiastic
and super supportive and also you know
incredibly smart and had these great
ideas and so that's where that's where
it really started you know where I
really discovered this combination of
engineering and life sciences and how it
could happen then I worked with dr.
Schuler at Cornell he is really the you
know the grandfather of bioprocess
engineering he wrote the book on that
and he was an incredible mentor um you
know really just kind of showed me how
it was done and then again worked with
dr. butcher who was brand new at the
time but I really learned a lot from him
about how to set up a lab and how to
work with students and so I feel like
I've had really great training and
really great mentors okay and a blingy
assistant professor I know like you have
a lot to work with in the lab and all so
other than lab do you have any that
hobbies I know you have couple of kids
and I thank you yeah so I have three
kids my oldest is in kindergarten she's
gonna be six next week and then I had
twins of almost two years ago they'll be
two in June so um well pretty full but I
feel very lucky about that so free time
is most
we hanging out with those guys we um go
outside to go to the park we go on hikes
we hang out with our dog so that's
that's what we do for fun okay and let's
talk about your lab like that student
postdocs like how big it is and how do
you manage them sure um so I have just
recently so i'm in my sixth year at
Binghamton so just recently I've had my
first PhD students graduate over the
summer I had sagita hall in Courtney
sokol ish you're going to see some of
their work in the presentation these is
now a research associate down at
Columbia and Courtney is a postdoc at
Texas A&M they're really cool stuff and
then my third PhD student just graduated
this winter Sarah Mina and she's now at
MIT you're going to see some of her work
as well though they're all doing great
and I'm very excited for them and now
after they've graduated I have three
more PhD students um I have zonia guo we
call him he goes by Lenny I have Fabiola
marina Olivas and she is also working on
GI tract work and then I have Jonathan
bramsin let's see so those are the three
PhDs then I have one two three master
students and too many undergraduates to
count so I love the loves of undergrads
here the undergrads are great they're
very smart they do a lot of really good
work so I try to work with as many as i
can so that all out the work that i'm
going to talk about today there was
undergraduate involvement and so we all
wait let's say we meet um i meet
individually with students once a week
for about a half hour and we have group
meetings once a week as well and then I
try to keep an open door policy right
now excluded I left it closed now
because I didn't want to get I didn't
want to get interrupted but say I do I
try to leave my door open and I try to
you know be as available as possible
because um overall I find that you know
being interrupted for
something quick can save a lot of time
and a lot of frustration sometimes
especially when people are first
starting so yeah okay and you have
developed somewhat ed devices models and
all those things so hmm okay can we go
with the presentation so that we can
learn more about your work sure so you
want me to start the presentation now
it's okay thank you absolutely oh sorry
I just take me one second all right all
right can you see everything okay Nakia
cousin okay yeah got it okay yes okay so
um the work that I'm going to present
today is entitled development of
physiologically realistic so culture
models of barrier tissues and so are you
going to stop me anywhere and ask
questions if something isn't clear no
just keep going yeah keep going only at
the end I'll ask some questions okay
alright great well um I don't mind being
interrupted something seems unclear or
you know it's no it's no problem and I
probably went a little overboard with my
slides so I'll try to keep it to about
40 minutes but okay that might be that
that might not happen okay um so so just
to kind of introduce the you know kind
of the background and the motivation for
our work um so right now in preclinical
testing of new pharmaceuticals in vitro
cell cultures or animal models are
really the two ways that these new drug
candidates are tested and the question
is can these results that you get from
two-dimensional cell cultures there that
are in a static dish or from in vivo
animal models be extrapolated to humans
the answer is they can but it doesn't
really work very well and that you can
see that from the failure and clinical
trials um about twenty-five percent of
drugs fail from lack of efficacy about
twenty percent for toxicity about twelve
percent for clinical safety issues and
over overall the cost is enormous your
looking at about a 15 year process in an
investment of about 2.6 billion dollars
so there's a lot of room for improvement
in the development of new drugs and I
have this nice chart that my student
Courtney made I tried to put all the
publications down in the corner so that
if anybody wants to read more about it
you have access to those citations so
this nice graphic that she made really
shows the current state so where you
start on the right in time and at time
zero so at time zero and a maximum
number of potential compounds and you
look at how much time it takes and the
thinning out of compounds over time
where things get really critical so you
have these preclinical trials so let's
say that you have 5,000 10,000 potential
new drugs about 250 or 1% might reach
clinical trial or preclinical trials so
from there you go in to face one all the
way up through phase three trials those
are a huge investment and that's where
these drugs are being given to people so
there's a lot of drop out a lot of
toxicity a lot of lack of efficacy so if
we could find a way to help these
potential drugs fail faster then there
could be a lot of money and say
potential morbidity that is saved and so
that's really the overall goal for the
type of work that we're doing oh just to
put that on the slide what our research
goal is is to create more realistic
representations of human tissues so this
can be for studying new drugs or
compounds for admin or absorption
distribution metabolism elimination and
toxicity or to try and study disease
progression on novel treatments or
treatment regimes so what we're doing is
trying to use engineering methods to
really create the simplest organ or
tissue mimic that can recreate most of
the function of these organs or tissues
in the body so that's really the goal of
what we're doing and so just to give you
a quick outline I have a few different
projects that I've been working on and I
wanted to give little
sound bites and pieces of all of those
because I couldn't pick one and so um
the first again we really focused on
barrier tissues so we're looking at
things like the GI tract and kidney and
that the vascular endothelium so the
first is taking this GI model I started
working with this when I was at PhD PhD
student and looking at how nanoparticle
ingestion effects gastrointestinal
testimo health and function so you might
not realize it but nanoparticles are
becoming a really common food additive
and there's no additional fda approval
that's required as long as the bulk
material that they're made from is
approved the problem is that when you
take these in these materials and you
bring them down to a nano-sized they
really start behaving very differently
and we're finding that they have some
some interesting effects on the way that
our gut functions next I just want to
talk briefly about trying to develop an
in vitro model of the gut microbiota I
think that if you study the gap the GI
tract if you ignore the microbiology
side you're really missing a huge
component and so we've started working
with bacterial and epithelial
co-cultures then I'm going to talk about
our microfluidic device that models the
human proximal tubulin come Mary list
which are the important are two
important parts of the kidney and then
finally talk a little bit about
endothelial to mesenchymal
transformation so this is our 3d model
of the endothelium and it's studying a
very specific cell process that occurs
called endothelial to mesenchymal
transformation so those are the things
that I'm going to go through so to start
with again we're going to start by
talking about looking at the role of
nanoparticle ingestion on GI health and
function so this model of the GI tract
is based on cell cultures there are more
to life cells the first cell type that
we use a lot is called caco-2 cells
these are a cell line so they're
different they are derived from a cancer
cell and they can grow indefinitely in
culture but what's really cool about
these cells
that when you grow them for two weeks
they differentiate into a cell type
that's really close to absorb different
arrow sites and that's what you're going
to find in the small intestine and in
the colon so what I wanted to you know
the reason that i have this slide is
just to show you that this type of cell
expresses all the nutrient transporters
and they have all the main transport
mechanisms that you're going to see in
the body the next cell type that we use
a lot for this model is called ht29 mcx
these are gastric mucous secreting cells
so they act like goblet cells goblet
cells out the second most common type of
cells that are present in the GI tract
and you can see that up over here when
we culture these caco-2 s in ht29 MTX
cells together you actually get this
mucus layer that forms right over the
top of your model layer so there's a
nice mucus layer that's there and so let
me have these cocultures of caco-2 in
ht29 MTX our mostly using this ratio of
75 to 25 that you have a culture that
represents the two most common types of
cells that are in the intestinal
epithelium and you have this nice mount
a layer of mucous that forms over your
cell monolayer and so this is a little
confusing food there's a lot going on on
this slide but I just wanted to talk a
little bit about some of the nutrient
transport pathways that we're looking at
so what our lab has done is develop
these functional assays so we wanted to
see how a really common food additive
effects the way that our cup functions
so we've been looking at gene expression
and protein expression and functional
transport of different nutrients and so
I just wanted to quickly outline a
couple so glucose that's you know sugar
so this is transported in by the sglt1
transporter transported out of the gut
by glute to so on the top of this this
is representative of the intestinal
lumen and down here this would be
representative of the capillary network
so this is how these nutrients are
absorbed into the bloodstream fabp is
going to transport medium and long chain
fatty acids iron is transported by dy
CTP and dmt one transport
out of the cell by FP and one and half
station and then finally we look at zinc
zinc is transported into the cell by zip
zip and CRT transporters and Z and T 1
is what transport zinc out of the cells
so later when I show some of the gene
expression results that is what I'm
referring to is these specific
transporters so again this has this
slide has a lot going on but I just
wanted to give you an idea of what the
experimental design is here so this is
actually a static culture so this is
cells that are grown in a trance fault
insert we take our nanoparticles so
we're specifically looking at nano
particles that are commonly present in
food so we've been looking at titanium
dioxide nanoparticles silicon dioxide
nanoparticles and zinc oxide
nanoparticles so titanium dioxide is
commonly used as a whitening and a
frightening agent you'll see it in a lot
of processed foods silicon dioxide often
is used to help prevent aggregation or
food from sticking together you'll see
it in things like a soup packets
titanium dioxide you'll see in like for
example white frosting there's lots of
titanium dioxide zinc oxide is commonly
used to prevent oxidation of foods that
are put in a can so you'll see it on the
interior lining of like of canned food
and so we try to make estimates of
physiologically realistic doses so how
much tio2 or sio2 a person might
normally consume in a meal and that's
what we're exposing our model too so a
lot of the time in this research these
nanoparticles people will use really
really high doses and the part of the
doses that we're using we're actually
really pretty low so you're talking
about on the order of let's see it's 1
times 10 to the minus 8 nanoparticles
per centimeter squared which I know
that's kind of a crazy crazy dose but
what we do is we try to normalize the
exposure of nanoparticles to the surface
area of the gut so if you had a dose of
tio2 how much exposure would the size of
our culture
or how much exposure to the GI tract
would be representative by the size of
our culture so we try to normalize it to
number of particles per centimeter
squared so again we're using pretty low
doses so we can digest these in a tube
we can add them to our culture of
intestinal epithelial cells we can look
at nutrient transport so again we look
at fatty acid uptake we look at glucose
transport we look at iron and we look at
zinc um and we can do a cute which are a
four hour exposure or chronic which is
exposure over five consecutive days and
then we do our measurements so we look
again at nutrient transport we look at
gene expression we look at reactive
oxygen species protein expression to see
how these things are affecting gut
function and so what we found is that in
response to these physics these really
pretty physiologically relevant doses at
nutrient transport and uptake are
sensitive to the to this particle
exposure and in general especially if we
look at this medium dose what we're
seeing is that the nanoparticles really
decrease transports following both so up
here we're looking at acute exposures
and then debt over on the side we're
looking at chronic exposures I know that
this these are a little bit small but
this is iron transport after acute
exposure zinc transport after chronic
exposure or this is a cute and this is
chronic and so again overall what we're
seeing is that these medium doses are
causing a decrease sometimes that I
hired a higher dose we're seeing an
increase and in general that's because
the barrier function tends to be
disrupted at those higher doses um we
also see some changes in protein
expression so we look to see how tio2
particles affected the tight junctions
so the junctions in between cells so
that's a measure of barrier function and
we saw that at some of the especially
chronic at the higher doses we see some
increase in the permeability of those of
these gut models and we also see some
active oxygen species that are produced
and this i knows is a lot too to
summarize this what we're looking at
here is a panel of nutrient transporter
and inflammatory genes what we see I
think probably the take home message
here is that for these chronic exposures
some of our pro-inflammatory genes we
see an upregulation in those so this is
after a five the exposure to the low
medium or high doses of these tio2
nanoparticles we start to see an
increase in these in pro-inflammatory
genes so the next question that we asked
is okay so you might be exposed to these
nanoparticles if you're eating you know
kind of common processed foods and this
might be affecting the way that you
transport nutrients but what is the
reason for it so at least for titanium
dioxide the next thing that we did was
we took some electron microscopy images
of the microvilli so microvilli are
these little finger like projections
that come up from the apical or the
intestinal side of these cells and what
they do is they create all kinds of
extra surface area for absorption of
nutrients and what we were seeing is
that after exposure to these
physiologically relevant of doses of
tio2 that we saw lots of decrease in
microvilli and so what we think is
happening is that um after exposure to
these nanoparticles the microvilli are
damaged and what that's doing is
decreasing the transport of nutrients so
this could be something that's happening
in the body if you're exposed to a lot
of nanoparticles again you're going to
see a lot of these nanoparticles things
like tio2 and things like candy and
sweets um and so a you know we think
it's something that's worthy of study um
so that's that's all i have about that
project for right now again we're doing
more work with silicon dioxide with zinc
oxide which are also commonly consumed I
nanoparticles and looking to see how
those affect got function as well
um so the next thing that we're doing is
trying to engineer a microbiome so
trying to understand how the bacterial
populations that are present in the gut
are affecting gut function and so
similarly we're starting with a with a
static model and we're working towards a
fluidic model but here we're adding
bacteria to this top chamber of our gut
model and so one really interesting
thing that we've seen is that when we
have beneficial bacteria so we've been
working with El rhamnosus GG so this is
a known beneficial strain of bacteria
when we expose these guts cultures to
the same concentrations of tio2 when
bacteria are present they actually help
to remediate some of those effects that
we saw on microvilli you can see that
with glucose transport as well and so
here this blue line is the control so
that's exposed to you nothing and that's
how those cells transport glucose when
cio 2 is added you see a significant
decrease in glucose transport and then
when you look at the cultures with
either Algrim gnosis jeje or elrom
gnosis plus di 02 there's no significant
difference in between these two cultures
as far as transport of glucose goes so
we think that's pretty interesting and
we'd like to see I would like to study
more how these bacteria are maybe
modulating the effects of food additives
that might be considered detrimental to
gut function um so just to quickly
conclude we saw that tio2 nanoparticles
which are commonly interested in a
particle from processed food that
they've significantly affected iron zinc
lipid nutrient lipid nutrient transport
and also intestinal alkaline phosphatase
activity we've shown that these tio2
nanoparticles affect gene expression and
reactive oxygen species formation and
that that they're also able to decrease
the number of intestinal microbial which
decreases the surface area available for
nutrient absorption so overall what this
study is indicating is
but the intestinal epithelial cells of
our gut are affected on a functional
level by these physiologically relevant
exposures to tio2 nanoparticles again a
disclaimer this is an in vitro study so
outside of the body but again we feel
like it's a it's it's interesting and
where they're worth the further study um
so the next thing that I wanted to talk
about is a microfluidic device that can
model the human proximal tubular
meritless so again these are portions of
the kidney um so just to briefly or aunt
to the kidney on the function of the
kidney in the body is for filtration for
Ozma regulation of the blood and for
reuptake of compounds from the
glomerular filtrate um so the kidneys if
you're talking about drug exposure
they're going to play a large role in
this admin so absorption distribution
metabolism elimination and toxicity so
the kidneys are filtering out everything
from our blood so you can imagine that
they're going to be exposed to anything
that we take that's a that's a
pharmaceutical some other physiological
parameters related to the kidney um
normal function there's the ggt enzyme
that's a that's a common enzyme that's
present after and transport and active
transport that's the way that these
kidney cells transport materials that
have been filtered out of the glomerulus
they transport them back into the blood
in the disease state there can be
fibrosis or lots of alpha smooth muscle
action protein expression altered
alkaline phosphatase activity for
example so those are all things that I'm
going to talk about later as far as the
results go a few different renal disease
states you can have fluctuations in your
canary little filtration rate that can
happen due to hypertension or high blood
pressure um if you have diabetes you can
have very high blood glucose kidney
stones are the formation of calcium
oxalate crystals in your in your kidney
kind of fluidics and nephrotoxicity is
the result of for example a drug that's
incompatible with these cells so those
are a few of the disease states that
we've
actually work to recreate with our model
um so just to talk briefly about the
cell line that we work with here so
again we're our goal really is to work
on making these models so we have to
work with cell lines which are are easy
to culture and they call variable to be
cultured and definitely there is always
the possibility of using primary cells
or even using a patient's own cell and
these devices but again our focus is
making the devices not on making new
breakthroughs as far as the cells go so
we've been working with that HK to cell
line these are human origin cell line
they form the D lining up the proximal
tubules um they're able to express ggt
which is a normal enzyme that's present
in the in the kidney and they form a
nice barrier properties those barrier
properties or maximum at about day too
so that's usually when we do our
experiments they do express the proteins
that were interested in so caveolin-1 is
able to transport these materials and
vesicles from the gumerry where filtrate
back into the bloodstream they express
occludin which is a tight Junction
protein showing that they have that nice
barrier property and they also express
clathrin which is another transport
protein forms endocytotic pants so these
are just pictures showing these kidney
cells I'm expressing these proteins um
and after doing that characterization we
just said ok hk2 is going to be a good
representative cell line for a kidney
model it's well differentiated its able
to express these normal functional
proteins and enzymes and it is able to
transport materials the same way that
these cells would in the body um so the
next thing that we wanted to do the
advancement that we wanted to make so
there's definitely other groups out
there that have developed models
microfluidic models of the proximal
tubules and what we wanted to do is
include glomerular filtration not
something novel and so the way that we
mimicked glomerular filtration is in
this device which is shown here it's a
housing that has a 50 kill adult and
molecular weight cut-off filter so it's
got an eight nanometer filter and it
provides a passive filtration barrier
similar to the way that happens in the
quill meritless and so what this is
showing here is just that BSA so we were
using bovine serum albumin in the body
it would be albumen from a bloodstream
is filtered in a way that is consistent
with how BSA for how women would be
filtered in the body um so we took this
another step further and we actually
made this glomerulus living so we seeded
endothelial cells on to one side of our
clone aerialist shown in pink here and
we actually added a number of layers of
extracellular matrix on both sides of
the membrane as well so on this side we
had collagen and chondroitin sulfate and
then collagen and then on this side with
endothelial cells we also had
fibronectin and so these were also
representative of the extracellular
matrix that are present in Mary Alice
and so this is a couple schematics that
show the entire device so the whole
device was made out of polycarbonate
polycarbonate is a nice material to use
for drug studies because it is inert and
it doesn't absorb or leech any compounds
into um your whatever fluidic medium
you're using there's an independent top
and bottom channel to this so there's a
top flow chamber on a bottom flow
chamber so you can actually measure
transport through that proximal tubules
and there's a polycarbonate membrane
which is shown here and these dotted and
these dots and those are what holds the
cell monolayer so this is a picture of
the device this is the setup so there's
a top fluidic channel that goes across
the cells there's a bottom fluid a
channel that can measure the transport
through those kidney cells and then
finally there's the school Mary Liz
device which can actually filter out
proteins in a similar way that you would
see in the body and this is just an idea
of how the flows
it works right here with a pump that
pumps everything and so we did some
characterization of the way that these
cells behaved under static in fluidic
conditions so clathrin is one of the
main active transport proteins for a
shear stress beauty of point eight times
per centimeter squared which is
physiologically realistic this is a
picture of the static cells so the blue
is DNA and the red is beta catenin and
then the greenness clathrin and so this
is the protein expression under static
cultures and then you can see this
dramatic change in protein expression
under fluidic conditions so they express
lots of this clathrin protein they're
able to do lots more protein transport
and then this is just a an actual
quantitation of those images that we
took of clathrin and beta-catenin
protein expression compared to static so
this is static culture and this is
fluidic 415 24 and 48 hours um we also
looked at the total transport and the
passive transport both in static and
fluidic conditions and just overall
found that these fluidic cells are able
to transport a lot more protein we
looked at cell viability on our
glomerulus so we struggled a little bit
with getting those endothelial cells to
survive on the glomerulus and what we
found is that we had to cede at about a
hundred thousand cells per centimeter
squared we had to do all those layers of
extracellular matrix that I was telling
you about where we had collagen that was
Sam chondroitin sulfate that was
sandwiched between collagen layers and
then fibronectin that the endothelial
cells were seated on too but we did
reach a nice viability this is just a a
stain that shows that those cells are
alive and they're forming a nice model
layer and then what we were able to show
is that with all these cells in this
device that they could actually filter
BSA in a way that was similar to what
you would see in the body so this is at
time zero and this is after two hours
and so this red line right here is
showing you the BSA or albumin
concentration that's in the top
and then similarly you see a rise in the
blue line which is the amount of BSA
that we were measuring in the bottom
chamber of the device and so this red or
no the green right here showing you the
amount of BSA that's being taken up by
that ku Mary Liz device and you can see
the differences in the way that the BSA
is transported so these are the end of
the helix which are endothelial cells
you can see that the BSA which is in
green is really shown in the in between
the endothelial cells so it's passively
I'm moving in between the endothelial
cells you compare that with HK 2's which
are the kidney proximal tubule cells you
can see that the BSA shows up at these
as these little kind of globules and so
that's most likely being actively
transported with Katherine and endocytic
vesicles so in our device the BSA is
being transported in the way that it
would be in the body so we thought that
was pretty cool and so this wasn't in
the publication that's out already but
we do have these pot of sites now so
normally in the glomerulus you have
endothelial cells that line that mind
the blood contact contacting side and
that blood is filtered through the
glomerular membrane and this is
controlled by these pot of sites that
are on this opposite side so you have
blood that's filtering through on the
endothelial side on the other side you
have this culinary allure filtrate which
is eventually going to become urine and
so um these podocytes are what they do
is they control that filtration through
the the slit diaphragms they're able to
they have these long finger like
projections and are able to control the
size of the pores and change the size of
the pores that allow for filtration
there are also size and charge and shape
selective and there is an immortalized
cell line that you can work with it's
the CI HP one cell line we have those
cells now these are what these
differentiating Prada sites look like a
day 18 and we are seeing these on the
other side of our climber uhler membrane
and we're going to do some more
experiments that we are currently now
but we don't have
a lot of results with those yet so
that's just going to add another layer
of physiologically relevant logical
relevance and in complexity to our
kidney model so just to quickly conclude
again this microfluidic model can
recreate some of the normal functions of
the kidney um we've able to would we've
been able to induce some various disease
dates including things like kidney
stones and high glucose like you would
see in diabetes and high flow rate like
you would see in hypertension and this
is the first microfluidic device that's
had merula filtration of of primary
urine um so finally in the last couple
minutes I'd like to talk about the
mechana biology of endothelial timas
animal transformation so the the overall
motivation of this or the the model that
we've created here which is the
three-dimensional model of the
endothelium can be applied to a couple
different problems for this particular
project we specifically been looking at
calcific aortic valve disease so over
here we have a picture of a normal
aortic valve here this is what a
calcified a ortak valve looks like we
know some of the risk factors for why
this starts looking like this but we
don't know the exact disease mechanism
so how what the process is the other
problem with calcific aortic valve
disease or CA VD is that there's no
biomarker that's present that can tell a
clinician how far advanced your your
valve diseases and there's no
phonological therapy that can that
exists that can help to reverse it once
those once that disease process starts
so pretty much what happens is once you
start to have enough valve insufficiency
and you're affected enough by it you
have to have the valve replaced with a
prosthetic valve and that's the only
treatment that's that's that exists
right now CA vdf X about 2.5 percent of
the population and there's an annual
spending on it of over 27 billion so any
way that we could try to understand the
disease process better and study
potential pharmaceutical
rupees for it would help to would
benefit people that are suffering from
CA VD so just a quick intro to the
aortic valve so this right here is a
relatively normal valve and it turns
into something that looks like this
where you have these calcified nodules
there's also also these different layers
of the aortic valve so you start on the
fibro so which is this side right here
and on the fibrosis I'd you have
anything illegal cells on the interior
of the valve you have interstitial cells
and this fibrosa is primarily made up of
collagen when you get to the spongy oh
so which is shown here kind of been
great this is kind of like the shock
absorber of the valve so there's
interstitial cells and there's lots of
glycosaminoglycans and then you have the
ventricular right here and that is the
side that is exposed to the ventricle of
the heart this right here is going to be
exposed to the aorta so there's lots of
the last in here and then you have your
endothelial cells so this allows this
part of the valve to be relatively
flexible and so what we're interested in
is the cell process called endothelial
Tumas animal transformation so what
happens here and it's it's really
interesting and it's something that has
really only recently started to be
studied as in adult populations at least
so what happens is you have these mature
adults endothelial cells and they start
to lose their cell cell contacts so they
start to break away from the neighbors
they start to lose their endothelial
markers so things like VT cat hearin or
pikia MERS / cd31 and they start to gain
the Zen como markers like alpha slim
less selected then they start to gain
these invasive and migratory properties
and so they turn into these activated
fibroblasts and they can invade down
into the matrix this this is a process
that's been studied since the late 70s
involved development so in embryonic
valve development but really is much
more recently been connected to adults
and we see it happening in fibrosis
people have see it happening near tumors
so in cancer and we also see it
happening right around valve disease so
this might be something
that is causing remodeling of the
extracellular matrix it might be a
beneficial or pathological process so it
might be involved in valve regeneration
or valve disease but we'd like to know
more about what the process is and why
it's happening and so this is some of
the work that I did as a postdoc we
showed that nmt is occurring in valve
disease so again we know that it's a
valve morphogenetic mechanism and we can
say here that its associated with a
biotic valve disease it's really only
occurring on the fibrosis ID and the
fibrosis side of the valve again is
where these calcific nodules are forming
we know that it's induced by tgf-beta
one we know that it's induced by oscilla
tori shear stress and we know that it's
induced by pathological strain all in in
in vitro so here what we're showing is a
calcified valve that's been removed from
a human patient and just to blow up that
picture right here what we're showing
here are the cells that have undergone
and Mt so they're closed stage for these
endothelial markers and these physical
markers and they've invaded into the
valve matrix so again this is just
showing that end MT is associated with
valve disease so it's happening when you
also have these calcific nodules um just
a little bit more about valves again on
this 8a ortak side you have these the
way that the valve opens and closes when
that valve closes you end up with these
Louis Silla tori shear stresses on the
aortic side versus a high steady shear
stress on this ventricular aside and
again on this fibrosis side is where you
see these calcified nodules that are
forming um and that's just one more
thing that we looked at with our
microfluidic models is different shear
stresses and how that changes and empty
so we know that proteoglycans and
hyaluronic acid are present as well near
these calcified nodules so valve disease
this is a picture this is the section of
a diseased valve and so you can see
these are these calcified nodules and
this valve has also been stained with
MOBAs penta chrome and so what we're
seeing is that there's lots of gags so
there's lots of chondroitin sulfate and
dermot answer
sulfate rich proteoglycans in that
fibrosa lair in the early stage and then
later in this valve disease process
there's the present of hyaluronic and
this is all near those calcified nodules
so right now we know that end MT is
present near the calcified nodules and
valve disease and we know that
glycosaminoglycans which are normally
only present in that middle shock
absorber layer of the valve are also
starting to migrate up into the fibrosa
and right around the calcific modules
during bowel disease so this is on to
our work right here we kind of tried to
put those two things together and what
we were finding is that gags are also
close to nmt so we know that nmt happens
near calcif it's calcified nodules we
know that gags are present near
calcified nodules in here what we're
showing is that in areas where there are
a lot of gags so this is a move at Penta
chrome stain so the gags are shown in
this kind of turquoise blue so we're
showing that in places where there's a
lot of gags there's also an empty
happening so these are cells that have
invaded into the matrix and their Co
stage for both um endothelial markers
and mazuko markers so we wanted to
explore this further we wanted to say to
try and understand what it is about
these gags invading the fibrosis aware
that are causing these endothelial cells
to change their phenotype and so the
research goals of this part of the
project were to try to characterize some
of the extracellular matrix and
endothelial cell interactions that are
impacting and mt and we're doing this
using these dynamic and
three-dimensional in vitro and also in
silico models so this is a collaborative
project with dr. peter playing and dr.
bruce marine the mechanical engineering
department of binghamton and so we're
using again these in vitro models in my
lab and the computer models that they've
developed to try to really characterize
this process so what we did is we in
vitro try to mimic the diseased valve
extracellular matrix so we're using
porcine a ortak valve endothelial cells
it's really hard to get your hands on
healthy human aortic valve endothelial
cells so we use pay cards and
get those hearts that are freshly
isolated from slaughterhouses and we get
those cells out and we're actually able
to induce disease in these healthy
porcine cells by changing different
properties so changing you know by
adding inflammatory markers are changing
the extracellular matrix so we can
actually induce and mt in these healthy
porcine cells so the first thing that we
wanted to do again we wanted to take
this 3d scaffold that we're growing
ourselves on and try to mimic early and
late late valve disease by looking at
different types and different levels of
gags being incorporated into that 3d
hydrogel so the next thing that we did
was do a scaffold characterization so we
were looking at the glycosaminoglycans
chondroitin sulfate or CS I've on
holonomic acid or a che and dermatan
sulfate or Diaz and we looked at
different levels we looked at collagen
gels with plus one makes per mil of
these collagen gels with plus ten MiG's
per mil of these and then collagen gels
with plus 20 makes prevail of these um
click hospital glycans and so again we
wanted to look at levels that were
mimicking early valve disease all the
way too late valve disease and in order
to really isolate out the contributions
of the different gags and just the
stiffness of the collagen what we tried
to do is mimic the stiffness of the
collagen from when we added those gags
so here we're using rheology and we made
stiffness matched collagen gels in order
to again try to separate out the effects
of just the glycosaminoglycans versus
just the stiffening of that Joe um by by
creating stiffness controls and so you
can see that there's no statistically
significant difference in the Youngs
modulus between the collagen only and
the plus gags gels for each of these
different conditions and so um if you
look at the healthy fibrosa of a valve
it's between point five and three
kilopascals severe calcifications about
500 kilo kilo pascal as if we're looking
at one of these valves in vivo so with
these three gels were able to mimic the
stiffness of either healthy or a
minimally cows
I'd fibrosa so our gels are in between
two and 37k PA so just to talk a little
bit about the methods that we're using
in this we're looking at cell phenotype
we're looking at protein expression
we're looking at gene expression and
we're doing these wash assays so here is
our in vitro model we do this in static
cultures and we also look at sheer
across the endothelial cells and we look
at the number of cells that are have
actually broken free from this mono
layer and invade it down into this
matrix so here's a nice picture that
shows one of these endothelial cells
invaded into that matrix so we're
quantitive we're quantifying the actual
change in cell phenotype we also use
amino cytochemistry or
immunohistochemistry to look at protein
expression so we look at endothelial
markers and we look at moes edible
markers like Elvis with muscle active
and then we look at gene expression
using real-time pcr we look at and then
t genes we look at fibrosis markers like
called 1 a 2 and then finally we've done
these washed assays and what these tell
us is what the cell binding strength is
too bad 3d extracellular matrix so in
order to put share across these these
cells we did we developed a 3d culture
microfluidic bioreactor so this is
actually made out of PDMS or silicone
and there's this little punch down area
right here which is a 3d chamber for a
collagen or collagen plus
glycosaminoglycan jail and so we're able
to put this 3d culture area with cells
on top and then put a fluidic put fluid
through this device using a pump and
this allows us to change both the
magnitude and the direction of the flow
so we've looked at steady shear and we
flipped a tassel ettore sheer across
these cells that are seated on that 3d
collagen gel or collagen plus
glycosaminoglycan shell and so what we
found when we looked at this in vitro
assay was that when we introduce gags
into our 3d matrix that it induces
payback invasion so it really induces
nmt so what we're looking at here is the
number of invaded cells and these are
the different conditions so this is I'm
chondroitin sulfate I don't
and this is Dermot and sulfate and we
see an increase in invasion over all of
these conditions so that again that
invasion is a marker form as animal
transformation and we saw relatively
similar results for the plus 1 and plus
20 make per mil gags um we also looked
at protein expression and so I think
these pictures really demonstrate the
dramatic phenotype change that happens
in these cells so these are what the
healthy control cells look like and so
they have lots of red this is that
endothelial marker and when you add the
gags to the gel they start expressing
all this green off-post the muscle actin
they start to break apart from one
another again they just exhibit this
really dramatic phenotype change and so
if you quantify that um acta to gene
expression then you again you can see
lots of really increased expression for
the addition of these gags to the 3d
matrix we also see an increase in
fibrosis so again once you have these
activated and a fibroblast that are the
result of an empty they can go down into
the matrix and start producing lots of
collagen or lots of other extracellular
matrix components and so call 1 a 2 is a
fibrosis marker and so we start seeing
lots of call 182 gene expression in a
couple different conditions that we
looked at and we wanted to understand
really why this was happening and so um
we did this wash assay which is where
you take your 3d hydrogel you put your
healthy cells on to it you let them in
here for a few minutes and then you use
a physiological solution to try and wash
them off and what we found is that for
the higher concentrations of gags and
with the addition of tgf-beta 1 which is
an inflammatory marker what we see is
less cells that are present during this
wash assay which means that the cell ECM
bond strength is less in those
conditions so that's what we think is
happening we think that as gags migrate
into the fibrosa of the valve that this
the endothelial cells can't adhere quite
as how it quite as well and that they'll
actually start to undergo this
transformation this endothelial to
mesenchymal transformation
um we also looked at some of the effects
of shear so we looked at static
conditions we looked at a low shear
stress steady shear stress and a high
steady shear stress and we found that
the high steady shear stress is going to
decrease invasion and decrease office
with muscle or the Zen como marker
protein expression we found that low
shear stress and tgf-beta one are going
to increase the intracellular gap
junction with so here we were measuring
the distance in between cells and that
high shear stress actually decreases the
junctional gap width so here we're just
trying to look at how the different
cells cell and cell ECM interactions are
changing the way that these cells behave
and here we looked at the way that shear
stress in tgf-beta one regulate
endothelial and zen kemal gene
expression and just found that the low
shear stress in general upregulated a
lot of these more and empty or pro and
mt markers so again the overall thing
that we're trying to answer is why and
MT is happening in valve disease and is
it a path for a generation or towards
disease so we're seeing these
endothelial cells that are that are
healthy they have nice strong sell sell
and sell ECM bonds when you start adding
inflammatory markers this is is you know
activating them may be causing
transformation this is our invaded
phenotype where they start to invade
into the matrix and then finally you
have these Zekrom only transformed that
have gone on to remodel the
extracellular matrix so we're showing
that the extracellular matrix
composition is changing that Excel ECM
bond strength and inducing the process
the nmt process we're showing that shear
stress and inflammatory markers are
changing the cell-cell bombs and so
actually inducing the formation of these
secondly transforms that was due to sell
sell bonds and so those two factors are
what are going towards forming and empty
and so um what this model is providing
is a way to understand some of the
chemical and biomechanical cues and try
to really understand this process as it
might be happening in the body and it
also provides a platform for actually
studying Udrih new therapeutics or new
therapeutic regimes and just quickly in
the last couple minutes I know I'm going
pretty long because this is such a
complicated process and there's so many
different chemical and mechanical cues
that are going towards it we've actually
been using a hybrid model to try to
understand and eventually be predictive
of the process so the objectives of this
computational model are to simulate the
endothelial transformation and invasion
into the extracellular matrix and to
eventually try to determine the
mechanical and chemical parameters that
influence this cell behavior so it has
because it's a hybrid model it has two
components so the first is this
stochastic model so we are modeling the
cell cell and cell ECM adhesion forces
they're determined with a random
sampling of the gamma gamma distribution
and there's four parameters that control
that there's the concentration of
glycosaminoglycans there's the
inflammatory cytokine population the
magnitude of the shear stress that's
acting on the endothelial cells and the
presence or absence of the Scilla Tori
shear um we're also looking at a
continuum transport and so there's a 3d
ECM domain there's a diffusive mass
transport of three chemical species
within the ECM and their source and sink
terms and nutrient wasted matrix
degradation enzymes the cell invasion is
based on a random walk so there is a
stochastic entropic forest and cell-cell
we're posting forces and half the tactic
forces are influenced by the cell
species in that continuum transport
model so this is the algorithm for how
this model works we initialize the
stochastic and continuum model
parameters initialize the computational
ECM domain stochastically model and mt
is random events we update transient
transport of chemical species
concentration throughout the ECM domain
stochastically model the concentration
dependent cell invasion and transformed
cells on by a biased random walk and
then finally we r et puis repeat steps 3
through 5
time step for a whole stimulate for the
whole simulation duration so these are a
few different results that we've gotten
using this model so this is a 24 hour
time elapsed time this is a 48-hour
elapsed time and this is a 200-hour
elapsed time quiescent endothelial cells
are shown in blue green are transformed
endothelial cells and then read this is
the side view are actually be invading
mazai komal cells so on the top what
you're seeing is the low concentration
of gags and inflammatory and then a low
steady shear flow on the bottom what
you're seeing is the low concentration
of gags high concentration of
inflammation and a high ocilla tori
shear flow so what you're seeing is the
way that the model is predicting that
these cells will undergo and empty and
invade into the matrix so the result so
far of the simulations are that varying
degrees of end mt cell invasion and
invasion depth into the extracellular
matrix are dependent on the model
parameters and that the model is most
sensitive to sell ECM force parameters
which is interesting because this is
what we were seeing really influenced
results in the in vitro model as well so
just to conclude on this project we've
shown that the presence of gags and low
shear both induce recyclable
transformation in endothelial cells we
think this is due to changes in the cell
ECM infusion most strongly and our
diseased human valves are also showing
that there's the Zen komal
transformation local to these gags we've
developed a hybrid model of end mt it's
most sensitive to variables that are
related to sell ECM forces and we're
hoping that as we are able to make
iterative design choices based on our in
vitro model results and it might
eventually be able to predict which
conditions are most critical to end mt
and finally we're finding that the
extent of cell invasion may not predict
pathology really the static and stiff
conditions had the most collagen
production by transformed cells so once
we put them into the more dynamic
conditions we saw much less collagen
production or fibrosis that was
happening
um so that's all I have for today so I
just like to acknowledge a few people so
this is Lenny zoning Go Go he is
graduating very soon and he did a lot of
the nanoparticle and titanium dioxide
work on this is sadita hog who worked on
the and mt project and he's down at
Columbia no this is fabio lima olivos
she's working on zinc oxide exposure in
the gut this is gabbie show who worked
on the nanoparticle project as well she
was an undergraduate she's at Minnesota
know as the PhD student Courtney sekolah
she did the kidney project she's down at
Texas A&M this is nicole martucci who is
going to be starting as a PhD student at
Pittsburgh she also worked on the
nanoparticle project Jonathan bramson
use a current PhD student who is working
on the end mt project this is peter
Tahu's at university of southern
california doing biomedical engineering
PhD in computational biology this is
Lynn Jean yang is a PhD student at Iowa
no this is jess funnel who's a current
undergraduate who's working on the
nanoparticle project and this is Sarah
Mina who is a recent graduate work from
an empty project in a salad at MIT um so
we'd like to I'd like to acknowledge
funding from NSF from NIH and from SUNY
Research Foundation also the Clifford D
Clark diversity fellowship that
supported Courtney Sarah and Jonathan
our collaborator dr. kenneth leung who
provided us with um he diseased human
valves and Owasco meat company which is
where we get our porcine cells and so
that's all I have for today thank you so
much sure um so let's see I can did he
get rid of this yeah ok so it was very
nice like I think you covered a lot of
ground with that yeah maybe maybe that
was too much but like i said it's hard
to take it's hard to pick one thing to
talk about yeah yeah I mean like I since
due to the lack of by my couple of
questions sure for first one is from the
initial part like you
add a bacterium to the this thing your
culture so it looks like it said
whatever the process the toxicity are
seeing is the reversible hmm have you
looked at any stem cells or anything
there in the inter Stein Oh as far as um
in testicles not a bug so that's yeah so
that's one thing I to acknowledge as far
as the gut I mean our gut is pretty
plastic and it has you know these villas
and in the villa scripts there are stem
cells present and they're always
producing new absorptive and goblet and
intero endocrine cells and so I you know
I don't think it's a good thing that
villain lair damaged by nanoparticles
but I don't think it's something that's
at that critical because our gut does a
pretty good job of healing itself it's a
place that's exposed to really extreme
conditions to know I haven't I haven't
looked at stem cells there was a more
relatively recent study out of MIT that
showed that when you culture these
caco-2 cells under dynamic conditions
that you can actually form all six types
of gut cells so the stem cells will
actually develop you'll develop these
villi you'll develop villa scripts um so
again we're moving that model more
towards a dynamic set of culture
conditions and so I think that would be
a really cool way to look and see how
these food additives might change cell
behavior using using that type of a
model and again nights with Keiko tues
which is so cool so you culture them
under these dynamic conditions and these
caco-2 cells which is the cell line
that's been around since the 80s can
differentiate into all six types of gut
cells which is just super cool okay
sorry hopefully I answered your question
you guys the second second part like the
glomerulus thing like filtration I would
like these nanoparticles in there to see
have any know so yeah so we haven't
really um the nano particles tend not to
really be absorbed so as long as the
barrier function stays intact you don't
see a lot of them actually make it
through we were actually doing icp-ms to
try and measure
caninum that had been transported
through our got model and we're finding
just about nothing and I icp-ms I mean
that measures to the parts per billion
um so it's not really getting through so
the nanoparticles that we adjust our
actually affecting a you know the side
of the gut that's on the inside the
intestinal lumen side not the blood side
um but I think that you know new nano
their new nanoparticle therapeutics are
our eminent some are already approved
and so using our kidney model to try and
see how they affect the kidney would
absolutely be a really cool application
ok but not something with your ID yet ok
and from the glomerulus model like he
does it filtered through the these
particles go through the kidney model so
all that we've tested so far is that BSA
so we've looked at a fluorescently
labeled bovine serum albumin and that
Mary lyst model does a really nice job
of filtering the BSA so nanoparticles
are even smaller than BSA but they do
tend to kind of collect together in
aggregate when they're in a culture
medium so I'm not sure if it would
filter these keys are nanoparticles or
not um but we can you know someday I
think we'll probably try and finally
like you have developed these cool in
vitro models so have you patented them
and are you thinking of anything
bringing them to noe yeah I mean so I
you know I'm still an assistant
professor um I'm a new faculty member so
really what I've just been focusing on
doing is you know trying to train good
students and present work and go to
conferences and try and get papers
published um so maybe it's not a good
business but so that's really been the
been my focus right now but maybe you
know maybe someday i did get yelled at
by our own IP office when we polished
our kidney paper without disclosing
anything to them but uh like I said I
just wanted to make sure that their
Courtney the student who did all that
work could go in
go to conferences and present her stuff
and get a good publication that's what I
was that was my concern yeah so I mean
like it's a it's a really interesting
work and certainly it has a lot of
potential to like grow and do more
things so again thank you so much for
taking time and it's fine oh look
forward to more of your work the near
future great thank you so much thank you